λα τα μουσία του κόσμου κι ότενα του ζητούσε κάτι δεν αντοποκρικνώνου αν πάντουται δεν
αρνιόταν κανείς να συνεργαστεί μετροβάσοτου καραιοργη ο πολιτισμός λοιπόν είναι το κύριο το κύριο πράμα
που μπορούμε εμείς να προτείνουμε χωρίς να ξεχνάμει την οικονομία δε λεότι φαζούμε εέραη οικονομία
είναι πολύ βαση κει εγώ βλέπω ότην οικονομία ως πολ βασικό τομέα τον οποίο χρειάζεται
χρειαζόμεν στε παντοται στην καθημερινί ζωή και σε εδικές περιπτώσης σας πάρα λίγο ξανάπισως τα
πολιτικά ένα από τα παλαιότερα μέλη του δημοκρατικού συναγεσμού το κύριος σπίτσα θεωρείται πως το
κόμμα ο δημοκρατικός συναγελμός θα ξεπεράσει σύντομα την κρίσει που βρίσκεται κατακαιρούς μετα ιδικά κια
τις προετρικές εκλόκιές και την εκλόγη τον υποχριστόδολή είναι πολύ ατυχές υτό που έγινε στς
συν τελευταίαεκρογική μάχειας ομε είναι λιπυρό γιατί πέρδεψε τα πράγματα αλλά βλέπω ότι ω συναιερμός
κατακάποιο τρόπο συνέρχετι και θα συνέρθει φροντίζουμε και εμείς παλιότερι αλλά καν πουλή νέοι και
η προερος τώρα είναι αρκετά ταλαντοχα η ανήτα δημτιο είναι ταλαντούχ πολιτικώς φυσικά είναι νερή
αλλά εγώ ότιν επιστεύουμε εσείς την επιστεύεσται άραίσως της τηρίξεται